hi i'm dr travis langley psychology
professor author of the book batman and
psychology
i'm here to talk about each and every
batman movie villain
batman the caped crusader dark knight
superhero without super powers he is
defined by his psychology so his
enduring enemies have to be defined by
their psychology as well
humble servant of his majesty
our first villain is dr tito dhaka from
the 1943
serial batman the year was 1943 at the
height of world war ii dr tito daca was
not directly a character from the comics
he was a type he was both a stereotype
and a villain type he fit that alien
menace by xenophobia fear of foreigners
and strangers played a role in this this
racist story it is a racist depiction
it is a character who
is acting very haughty it reflects
mirror image perceptions a mirror image
perception during a conflict is when
each side's perception
of the other
mirrors the other side's perception of
them americans were looking at a villain
such as dr daca wanting to see him
as being egotistical arrogant well that
was how americans were seen as well by
others so each side's perception
mirrored the other side's perception of
them
look at me martin
no no i won't but you will
next up the wizard from 1949 movie
serial batman and robin this is the only
appearance of the villain anywhere and
it really seems like the writers
themselves did not know for sure who the
wizard really was i think they changed
their mind part way through but by the
end he is revealed to be not the
scientist himself but the scientists
servants evil twin the evil twin
trope
also comes out of our fear of our own
dark sides our fear of
something that's not us imitating us
changelings
doppelgangers copying people duplicating
them to do evil deeds
that they themselves will be blamed for
you're going to temporarily extract
every bit of moisture from your body
let's talk about the penguin he wants to
be a crime lord
and he wants to be
a tycoon he wants both this is reflected
in him wearing a tuxedo all the time he
has what is informally known as a
napoleon complex the small man who wants
to be big his hat adds height his
umbrella extends his personal space if
he could lose some of that belly he
would not because it helps him be bigger
tim burton has turned penguin into a
physically
penguin-like little guy
great speech oswald
my name is not oswald
it's penguin
i am not a human being
i am an animal when the penguin after
some failures says i am not a man i am
an animal and he's blaming
his
physical differences in order to explain
why people won't accept him they were
accepting him it's his own behavior that
has caused his failure but he's looking
for an excuse this one hits on some of
what psychologist alfred adler called an
inferiority complex adler felt that most
of us are
largely driven by
a need to become superior to whatever we
are whatever we have been that in some
people they do it healthier ways than
others but for the people who feel
particularly inferior those who feel
outcast those who feel alienated that
they will be
obsessed with that need to overcome
their own deficits to try to feel
superior
[Music]
next up
the joker in the 1966 film batman the
movie this is the first film appearance
by the joker played by cesar romero who
would not shave his mustache for the
role we don't see anything that really
sets him apart from the rest of them
beyond his laugh
[Music]
they're all shallow and the joker is the
shallowest of them in this particular
movie
now we start getting greater depth of
character in this film the joker is jack
napier a gangster a psychopath who is
already
thought of
as
a bit reckless even for the criminals
jack is dead my friend
you can call me joker he says jack is
dead that's not really how we think of
people in psychology yes we can undergo
drastic changes our self concepts can
change trauma may alter us in ways that
we may never come back from but the same
psyche is still there
this is absolutely not the hilarious
joker
of the 1960s heath ledger did an amazing
job playing the most dangerous version
of the joker we've ever seen
the joker defies diagnosis his behavior
doesn't neatly fit any specific mental
illness beyond his obvious psychopathy
he has no conscience no empathy no
personal concern over right and wrong in
this film the joker is shown
as someone
with symptoms of tardive dyskinesia it's
a long-term consequence
of
some antipsychotic medications when he
makes these smacks of the mouth or the
flicks of his tongue those could be
long-term consequences of having
previously been on antipsychotic
medications i know a couple of
professionals who were bothered by that
they don't want
anybody to think that real life
individuals with tardive dyskinesia
are
that level of dangerous
this joker is the bad boyfriend he is
scary
for the sake of being scary it is very
superficial this joker is a punk
the character arthur fleck in this movie
is not the same as other jokers honestly
we can think of him as a different
character he is psychotic and what we
mean by psychotic is that they've lost
touch with reality the symptoms that we
most likely call psychotic are
hallucinations perceptions out of touch
with reality and delusions beliefs that
are out of touch with reality so
if you
see a two-headed monster because your
brain is conjuring a two-headed monster
that's a hallucination if you think you
are a two-headed monster that's a
delusion this is a character with
hallucinations and delusions he sees
some things he sees some people who are
not there there are other things within
the film when he gets beaten up by the
yuppies on the train
some of the movements they're making are
oddly similar to the kids who beat him
up at the very beginning through the
entire film there are things not to
trust
it just makes this wonderful psychotic
movie sick of maggoty
scratch
catwoman in the 1966 film batman the
movie catwoman gets a larger part in
this movie than the other villains
because she's playing a dual role she is
also pretending to be a russian
journalist called miskitka maintaining
the dual identity means you're lying all
the time in at least one of your lives
with this kind of dual identity
hopefully each is close to your heart
somehow this is more extreme much more
extreme than how we will bring different
personas to different situations in our
lives
there are rituals people go through to
have symbolic death ways of saying i am
no longer the person i used to be i am
now going to be someone else totem
psychologically is a symbol
that the person embraces
in order to represent deeper part of
their nature other part of their nature
a spiritual side of themselves
historically totems tend to be animal
figures which again plays into this
particular movie's animal theme with the
bat the cat and the chilly little bird
with selena and bruce they adopt these
symbols themselves she finds strength
from the cat symbol he finds strength
from the bat symbol they are both
becoming scary dark creatures of the
night because they want to let their own
darkness out while also managing it and
putting it to what for them
is a constructive purpose
they built from catwoman's story in
batman returns but taken out batman she
is
somebody who is very shy reserved unsure
of herself gets lit back to life by
kittens emerges sexier more aggressive
and that's it
this catwoman has some things in common
with bruce wayne they were both orphaned
at an early age and she understands
what that does to an individual catwoman
grew up poor though she did not have a
butler to be her confidant the version
of catwoman that we see in the dark
knight rises is an extension of that
they don't refer to her background but
she's very much being played that way
she does not neatly fit any disorder she
is not mentally ill she knows what she
is doing she is engaging in some
anti-social behavior she steals she
breaks into homes
those are anti-social actions
she
has empathy toward others even if she
tries to suppress it at times she is
not as heroic yet this is more of a
catwoman who's on her journey to
becoming more heroic
i see the way to do it
next up the riddler
the riddler as played by frank gorshan
in this film was just manic wired driven
by his compulsions the other villains
keep having to try to get him to settle
down
[Laughter]
the riddler is often cited as one of the
most narcissistic
the most egotistical most full of
himself
and the kind of criminals in real life
who send messages to authorities tend to
be pretty full of themselves too in his
case the riddle sending is a compulsion
he does not see it as a compulsion
because he wants to do it and you see
that in this film when the other
villains are saying this time just send
a straightforward message don't send a
riddle
and he grins and then laughs you can
call me
the riddler now we've gotten the fourth
of the big four who were all in that 66
movie now we have
the riddler played by jim carrey there
are some things he definitely seems to
be mimicking from gorson such as his
laugh and some physical movements and
there's a whole lot of jim carrey's
sense of humor in how he's playing this
character this individual edward nigma
as played by jim carrey adores bruce
wayne hates bruce wayne there's a great
book on borderline personality disorder
titled i hate you don't leave me the
psychologist character chase meridian
played by nicole kidman she
talks about this stalker who is sending
the riddles to bruce wayne she's
describing a lot of borderline
personality
without ever using the term
patient may suffer from obsessional
syndrome with potential homicidal
tendencies some people
with this condition will go to great
lengths to try to fill a void in
themselves not just stalking a person
but maybe by emulating them and you see
this rather drastically with edward when
he even does something such as where an
artificial mole to look like val kilmer
who's playing batman in this movie how's
my mole fine rejection
is hard on anybody but these are
individuals who may not be restrained by
consistent traits
and so their emotional action will be
more extreme
two-face in 1995's batman forever this
is the first live-action depiction of
two-face this version of two-face as
played by tommy lee jones is almost a
one-face because there's really not
variety in how he acts throughout this
film he does not in any way act like he
has dissociative identity disorder the
clinical term for what people commonly
call multiple personality disorder he's
not inconsistent in his behavior he
consistently wants to do wrong and this
one version of two-face will even cheat
he'll just keep tossing the coin until
it lets him do the thing he wants to do
somebody with an external locus of
control feels that events are caused by
what's outside themselves with two-face
as written throughout his history
he
actually has this internal locus but
he's angry at the world he's upset about
what has happened to his face and he
wants to take out that anger but he also
wants to be true to himself he he
doesn't want to think of himself as a
bad person
two-face
in 2008's the dark knight
tommy lee jones did not play a
complicated character aaron ercart is
playing a complicated character this is
an individual
who very much has an internal locus of
control he has made himself who he is
but now
his world view has been shattered by
what happened he did not have control
over getting abducted he is incredibly
angry he's taking out his anger on the
world he's starting with those that he
feels deserve his judgment but he will
also hurt innocent people along the way
something we see with a lot of these
characters just as with jack napier he
had undergone his accident in the acid
emerged as the joker and it brought out
some things that were in him already in
the film that he was already nicknamed
two-faced by a number of police and this
is unleashed and augmented some other
dangerous potential that had been there
this is the first film appearance of mr
freeze in 1997's batman and robin
the
version being portrayed here
is pulling heavily from an episode of
batman the animated series for his
origin in which his
alter ego had been renamed victor freeze
and he was motivated by trying to save
the life of his terminally ill wife he
is ruthlessly trying to do whatever it
takes to save her regardless of what it
does to anybody else regardless of how
she would think about it one of the most
poignant characters in batman's rogues
gallery this man with the cold
personality who had been warmed up by
the love of this woman who for some
reason was played by arnold
schwarzenegger in live action
poison ivy in 1997's batman and robin
the villains of this movie
are each individuals who are extremely
introverted perhaps some of the most
introverted characters in batman's
rogues gallery they both have some
qualities that may suggest that they're
on the autism spectrum let's go to the
book in the movie poison ivy says i am
not insane i've just been pushed too far
which brings us to that question is she
insane as depicted in this film what is
insanity insanity is a legal term
reflecting psychological states in which
the person is not responsible for their
own action
due to an inability to understand the
rightness and wrongness of their own
actions and she knows what she is doing
bane
in 1997's batman and robin this is
bane's first live-action appearance
he had only recently appeared in comics
for the first time ever he was supposed
to be batman's bane he was created to be
this enemy who could crush and break
batman in this film the chemical venom
has pumped him up he's steroided up
which was a popular topic of the time
he's this
thug who barely speaks who obeys poison
ivy for reasons we don't know he is
absolutely the most cartoonish version
of any
batman super villain ever brought to
screen
[Applause]
bane in 2012 the dark knight rises aside
from some superficial qualities he has
very little in common with the previous
version he's not even on venom he is a
mix of the comic book version of bane
and the al ghul's faithful servant ubu
of the three
needs that psychologist david mcclellan
identified as driving personality most
heavily needs for power
achievement and affiliation in the
comics bane is mainly driven by the need
for achievement in the film
is more motivated by need for
affiliation by his attachment to talia
al ghul by his loyalty to her and his
protectiveness of her yes he has things
he wants to achieve and he has power
that he is amassing but he is driven
most by loyalty to somebody else which
is not the comic book bane at all you
will never learn
[Music]
in 2005's batman v
this is the first live-action appearance
of raz al ghul or reish al ghul he's
something of a james bond villain thrown
into batman stories he is an
eco-terrorist his motivations are to
make the world a better place
there are definitely some
cult recruitment techniques that show up
in the way he approaches bruce wayne
it is
not the behavior of someone who's
recruiting just one of the minions
though it is someone who is trying to
recruit a new right hand somebody to be
at his side
this is the first live-action depiction
of the scarecrow jonathan crane played
by killian murphy he is the only villain
to appear in all of nolan's trilogy
which is appropriate because the trilogy
is about fear how it is caused how it's
inspired how it's overcome or how it's
used for other purposes in 2012 the dark
knight rises they are brought to him
afraid and they are sent out to be
afraid you are
philip striver executive vice president
of
daggett industries
they could just be killed no they're
going to be killed in a moment of terror
in these three movies we don't know
anything about his background he is not
the central villain and we don't really
see his motives we see him using fear
and his professional status to skirt
around the law and serve this other
purpose but we really don't know why
he's doing these things
what do you want i want to know how are
you going to convince me to keep my
mouth shut next up carmine the roman
falcone
in 2005's batman begins he is a mob boss
his role in there is to be a mob boss
and he wants power for its own sake the
need for power
is not
a complicated motivation
even characters where we see this great
need for power we want greater
complexity but with him
that is the thing he needs power
talia al ghul
in 2012's the dark knight rises
this is the first live-action depiction
of talia although she uses an alias
miranda through much of the movie her
goals are vaguely those of her father
trying to get what she wants and trying
to make the world better and reshape it
to what she thinks it should be
but
she's never given the depth of
characterization
of the other villains we could speculate
based on the way she grew up in a prison
in the middle of nowhere that she was
very motivated to try to live up to her
father's ideals we know from previous
movies that when al ghul referred to his
family he was talking about a family he
had before her he was not talking about
her so she was not that much on his
radar as a person so
based on her behavior she seems to be
trying really hard to live up to
her father and then the memory of her
father
next is hartley quinn in 2016's
suicide squad margot robbie plays harley
in
suicide squad birds of prey the suicide
squad
and surely
more to come harley quinn is something
of a social chameleon somebody whose
personality adapts to the people that
she's around when she's with heroes
she's more heroic when she's with
villains she's more villainous when
she's with mr jay she is more murderous
she is a strong capable individual who
sometimes does not recognize her own
strengths in the comics harley is
depicted as the daughter of a very
supportive mother and a con artist
children of
one parent who lies all the time tend to
go to two extremes either seeing the
worst in people expecting them all to
lie or they're in the habit of looking
for the best in this person who's lying
to them they're in the habit of
finding ways to justify putting up with
this person they will rationalize that
other person's lies this creates a very
gullible potential even though she is
smart enough that she has the ability to
see through these things she doesn't
always want to
max shrek
in 1992's batman returns a ruthless
industrialist named for the stage name
of the actor who played the vampire
count orloff in the silent film
nosferatu
he is a bloodsucker this is his only
appearance anywhere he has a strong
sense of entitlement he is not
completely psychopathic they give him a
son to show that he has some human
concerns he's just very ruthless and
sees a whole lot of these others as
inferiors or people who are in his way
he has grown up rich as well that's very
clear becoming wealthy
seems to be liberating to a lot of
people
people who become very wealthy
a number of them have said it frees them
to be
more of who they really are
so the one who has been more obnoxious
at heart they get to be very wealthy
they'll do it more extremely the one who
is a generous person at heart they get
to be very wealthy they might finally
get the opportunity to do these things
when max presents his public face he's
showing who he really is
[Music]
lex luthor in 2016's
batman vs superman dawn of justice lex
luthor is a character we typically see
in superman stories he is manipulating
batman to pit him against superman in
public he extols the greatness of his
father but in private he this is dad
pretty hard he is this rich boy who has
grown up to be powerful
to
represent
certain modern mega billionaires if
affluenza were a real diagnosis it might
apply to him and so
he does not seem to welcome anybody as a
potential fatherly figure in the world
he is threatened by batman and superman
especially superman in some ways he's
the cruelest of these villains that we
have seen
he will not just kill somebody he will
make sure
they know it's him he wants holly
hunter's character
to see the evidence to see the cruel
joke
and know that she's about to die and
everybody else in there too and she is
terrified and he does that just for the
sheer joy of it
in 2022's the batman we see
three
of the main villains that we've seen
before
riddler penguin catwoman three-fourths
of the big four
everybody except the joker because we've
seen a whole lot of joker lately we get
them
each featured in different ways each
representing different aspects of the
history catwoman and penguin seem to fit
more recent depictions in the comics her
as more of a socially concerned
anti-heroine penguin
as the
nightclub owner
mobster that he likes to be then the
riddler is a different version from what
we've seen
the riddler is the deadliest riddler
we've ever
seen depicted but it fits this story
about batman is detective and batman
struggling with his own violence
with batman when creators are coming up
with a new villain they have to start
with what will challenge batman as a
person so there is this rich rogues
gallery to go with this complicated hero